Thanks for coming out of
your, uh, lunch break today.
I appreciate everyone being here today.
I want to talk about,
I want to give you a brief
introduction to some things,
some initiatives we're doing
at the Monterey Bay aquarium,
kind of our approach to
problem solving and um,
and how we're trying to inspire
conservation of the ocean. Um,
as thanks for the introduction,
Kyle, as Kyle mentioned,
I oversee our research and science groups
and so I'm going to talk about some of
the things that we've been doing
for the past few years. Uh,
one of the really important things
to know about the aquarium is,
and even I was surprised about this
is we haven't been around that long.
We haven't even been around 40 years that,
but our roots go actually back pretty
deep and our roots are kind of based in
two institutions and one of
them is a Stanford University.
This is the Hopkins Marine Station that
started in 1890 to 125 years ago in
Pacific Grove, California.
They moved their initial lab,
which is what you see right here.
But what I love about this photo is that
this is what a marine biologist looks
like in 1892. Uh, it
looks rather Victoria,
but you still see the kind
of the shenanigans of the
people hanging out on the
roofs. Everyone wants to
be a marine biologist. Um,
but not everyone knows what
a marine bio just looks like.
This is what a marine biologist
looks like. Um, we're also,
uh, so that spirit of,
of, uh, investigation and research
is very alive in what we do.
The other institution is one much
closer to where we are right now.
And that's Hewlett Packard. Um, uh,
HP founded in a garage in Palo
Alto, arguably one of the, uh,
by David Packard and Bill Hewlett,
David Packard's daughters. Uh,
we're the ones that founded the aquarium.
And so the spirit of innovation from
Silicon Valley and the investigation from
Stanford is really where our
roots are as an institution.
We've been science-based
from day one and a,
and we owe a lot to these
two institutions. David
Packard is sometimes, uh,
you know, he's widely viewed as
a, as a titan of silicon valley.
His supervisor at Stanford, uh, Terman is,
is widely referred to as the
father of Silicon Valley.
And Terman got his phd at Mit
with Vannevar Bush, if you,
that name sounds familiar. He wrote
science, the endless frontier.
He was the first science advisor to a
US president to FDR. And so our roots,
if you academics love to trace their roots
back to where it started and Vannevar
Bush at MIT is, you could argue is
that's maybe where the aquarium started.
So this is the aquarium.
This is a view off our back deck.
I would say that our secret
sauce is that we're about place.
We're about the Monterey
Bay. Um, and as you can see,
maybe this wasn't taken
today cause it's raining. Um,
but it's a glorious place.
There's a lot of amazing creatures and
ecosystems just in the Monterey Bay. Um,
and it's an interesting story about the
history of conservation in Monterrey.
It wasn't always the way it is today.
Um,
it's a story of fisheries collapse of
immigrants coming in and bringing new
technologies of the sociology of
that always not being perfect,
but working things out.
It's a story of marine protected areas
and the ecosystems actually returning and
the fisheries coming back.
And so it's not always been an easy story,
but the story of this place I
think is very important, uh,
for marine conservation and
the story of the ocean. So, um,
that's where we are.
Um,
one of the things that we're working on
in the science team is to solve problems.
And even though we have roots in
academia and in Silicon Valley,
um, we are, you know, we have,
we're a modest operation. We,
there's only so much that we can do.
And so we want to solve a problem.
Of course we're going to bring
science to bear on that problem.
That's what our research
group help support.
But we also bring policy and we also
do quite a bit of communication.
And so our theory of change
is not necessarily, um,
focusing on one of those,
but doing all of those and trying
to do all of them really well.
We have around 2 million people that come
into our physical building every year.
And we have, you know, um, um,
too many people and we probably have
about 50 times those engagements online.
So we have an incredible ability to
reach people and educate them about the
ocean.
A great example of this combination of
science and policy and communication is
the Seafood Watch. Um, it's an APP.
It started as a paper card that a consumer
could use to make the best choices
about sustainable shellfish,
aquaculture,
fish or wild caught fish. And it
kind of works. A, you, you can, um,
if you're interested in Mahi Mahi,
you can look at the variety
of places that they come from,
the variety of ways they're
caught and choose the best,
most sustainable solution.
And so this is a great example.
We may not be able to reach
the scale of research that,
that a university could do.
We may not be able to do the scale of
policy that a federal agency could do,
and we may not have the communication
reach of an organization like Google,
but we tried to do all of those at the
same time to solve problems. So one,
a brief example of that,
Kyle mentioned Bluefin tuna.
We've been working on Bluefin tuna
in the Pacific, uh, for 20 years.
And it's an amazing
creature that, uh, we don't,
that we didn't know a
lot about at that time.
And we learned about a Bluefin tuna,
three tagging them and through tagging
them by putting a living tags on them,
the satellite tags that pop off and
then report a lot of data to us. Uh,
how deep the fish one, uh, its
migratory path, it's body temperature,
um, it's a celeron mitre
devices on there. Um,
and we tag them in the East Pacific
here and we develop these practices.
We innovated these techniques,
these surgeries to do these tags.
These fish are about 18
months to five years of age.
We tag them in the West Pacific and
Japan when they're of breeding age,
so much larger fish,
much more difficult to work with.
And we actually tag the
babies at the various stages.
And so the getting access to those places
really helps us understand where are
they going, how long they're there,
and they're complete life cycle.
And I mentioned that we do more
than research. Our goal of course,
is to recover the population.
Is it over 97% depleted
from its historical numbers?
And just past year we had a major
victory in getting all the tuna fishing
nations in the Pacific Ocean to
agree to recover the population.
And so while science and communication
and working through seafood watch and
celebrity chefs, um, this is our goal.
Now that we have a political agreement,
we really have to focus on how we're
going to rebuild it. Everyone says, yes,
we want to rebuild the population.
Now how do we do it?
Now Science and research is going
to come back to the forefront.
So this is something that I
really use to guide our team.
It's a quote from Ed Catmull who runs
Pixar, wrote a book called Creativity Inc.
I really love this because
when we bring scientists in,
we expect them to know science.
Yes, we may bring them in,
we may train them to do some things,
but we're really going for art.
And what I mean by that is, uh,
give you an example from Hawaii.
I lived in Hawaii for seven years.
I worked in a variety of
different capacities there,
but we had a problem of only having a
limited dataset of fish populations and
exploitation.
It only went back to about
1950 after World War II who
I wasn't even a state yet.
And we needed a longer term a data set
in which to make decisions to know about
the status of different fish populations.
And we have this gap.
You can see there's a gap
on the x axis between, um,
we have two points in 1900 and 1902 when
an economist came out and surveyed the
fish markets in Hawaii. And then we didn't
have any other data until 1950, 1952,
something like that. So what I did
is I went back and I found data,
um,
in restaurant menus in Waikiki
restaurants and we got about 500 different
restaurant menus. And
on these menus, we're a,
just a teeming with marine life
but was fascinating is about,
it wasn't always the same throughout time.
The early menus had all these fish on
there that were high value fish still
today,
but just were not being served in the
restaurants and the catch had gone down.
So we took a bunch of data off them and
we're actually able to fill in some of
the blanks over time because the menus
went back before the official catch
records did. So that was really
cool. And I have to tell you, uh,
finding these menus,
it's not like there's a Dewey
decimal number for restaurant menus,
so it's not like you just go to your
public library. I met some people in,
you know, in their garages. They're there
to, to their grandma in Hawaiian. I'm gay.
I would give them a box of something
and then they had it in the attic or
something like that.
We ended up getting 500 menus,
probably from a hundreds
of different sources. Um,
some people collected them as Curios,
as souvenirs of their trip to Hawaii,
a cruise from San Diego and the 1930s or
something like that. I cut him off Ebay.
I got them off craigslist.
Uh, all sorts of places.
I met a lot of great people and
heard a lot of great stories,
but the reason I'm showing
you this because of it's
because of this plot in the
lower rate, the green
plot, those are the data,
but this is my inspiration for them.
I'm sort of quoting the Nepali coast,
if that makes sense.
If anyone's been to the island of Kawaii,
it hasn't astounding coastline.
That's what that was.
I guess you could say it was sort of made
famous in the movie Jurassic Park when
the helicopter comes in. Um, but
this, these are the data here,
but we're trying to be artful about
it and we're quoting recycling.
This is a paper about Hawaii.
Let's show Hawaii somehow.
So the Nepali coast is
kind of embedded in this.
Another thing that we've been looking at
is modeling the risk to coral reefs and
the fisheries in the,
in those reefs.
Sort of like the fisheries fallout
from the collapse of reefs.
If you want to think about it like that.
And we're trying to think about all
sorts of ways to visualize the data.
And there is a map and here's
the sort of major ecosystems,
the top 29 ecosystems where reefs are
and we're ranking them and trying to
prioritize where risk lies the most.
Um,
but if you perhaps are familiar with
this band from the early eighties were
quoting this album, cover
a joy division. Um, and uh,
there's actually a package within the,
the software application are that
you can use. It's called joy plot.
And we're just quoting this joy division
because they're kind of a cool band and
it's actually a good way
to visualize the data,
but there's all sorts of ways to be
artful about how you discuss the story of
the data and how you visualize it.
And so that's one of the
things we're trying to do.
A big thing for us is how do we
observe and analyze data autonomously.
Um, you guys are probably in a
similar business, I would imagine. Um,
this sort of story begins with Rachel
Carson's book and the 1960 [inaudible]
silent spring.
And I think one of the things we really
learned from that is that there's no
such thing as a way what we say.
There's no such thing as a way. Um,
and if you're thinking about
sustainability, you're thinking about, um,
closing the loop, having a circular
economy, um, waste equals food.
You've probably heard of before.
One of my professors used to say,
and this consciousness is really
came because of Rachel spring.
If you throw something in a river,
it doesn't go away.
The river takes it to some other place,
right?
And so we're thinking about this in the
North Pacific in terms of microplastic
pollution, it's become, you've probably
heard about plastic in the ocean.
It breaks down to very small,
bit smaller than a millimeter,
then it's microplastic.
And then it gets into the food web and
it has toxins in the material of the
plastic. It absorbs toxins from the
water column. So on the surface,
and then it gets into the food web.
You've probably heard about these,
a great Pacific garbage patches,
these gyres,
which sort of physically
concentrate the plastic.
And one of the things that
that were really fascinated
by is those are not areas
of high biological importance.
We sometimes refer to them as
biological deserts. Actually,
there's area immediately to the south
of this gyre on the right and between
California and Hawaii where we've seen
a lot of great white sharks congregate.
It's called the White Shark cafe.
And we sort of refer to that as like
the burning man for white sharks because
they're going out to, a lot of the
males are going out to the desert.
We don't know if it's for to meet someone
special or if it's to get a bite to
eat or to have a, uh, an a,
an experience. Um, but, um,
this garbage patch, um, I, I've,
I've not been to the garbage patch,
but on the very periphery of it is the
big island of Hawaii and one of the
beaches they're called Camilo
beach is very famous for its sand,
essentially being plastic because it's
buffering right on the edge of that gyre.
And it just sort of scrubs like friction,
the plastic out of the water as
it hits the edge of that beach,
and I worked on sea
turtles a lot in Hawaii.
This little hawksbill turtle
is probably four months old.
It would fit in the palm of your hand
about nine centimeters long was at shell
and it had 41 pieces of plastic
in his gastrointestinal track.
It didn't make it,
and so there's,
this is a problem with animals
ingesting it. It's an acute challenge,
but there's also this longer
term challenge and we don't
know the implications.
Like I said,
there's a lot of plastic in those gyres,
but the area up top where it goes from
cool green to sort of warmer yellow and
red is this thermocline that we
know is a biodiversity hotspot.
It's a path along which whales and turtles
and large fish like Bluefin tuna and
swordfish travel, and it's where
a lot of fisheries congregate.
Now how do we get out there and measure
plastic at the scale of thousands
kilometers? If we're going to do
that, it's going to be a drone.
We can't afford to send big hundreds of
longs foot ships out there that costs
tens of thousands of dollars a day.
It's much more feasible to send a drone.
So we're going to work with them.
Bari,
the Monterey Bay Aquarium Research
Institute, that's kind of like,
it's kind of like your younger
sibling that gets all the cool toys.
That's kind of how embar he is for us.
And they have an exceptional talent of
creating sensors and putting them on
vehicles to go observe the places in the
ocean at scale and inaccessible places
like the deep, which is one
of the things they focused on.
And so we're developing technology
to monitor that transition zone,
that area of biological importance in
the North Pacific to really survey it for
plastics because we think that what's
going on with plastic in that place is a
lot more important than what's going
on in the desert by comparison because
that's an ecosystem biodiversity hotspot.
So not only observing the data,
but interpreting and analyzing
the data needs to be autonomous.
We're using this is,
you're not meant,
you're not supposed to see
all these individual plots.
There's 268 a spectra from microplastic.
Every little piece of plastic that
we have pulled out of the ocean,
we have to read with a, um, to read
their spectrum to determine what it is.
And we cannot do that manually.
So we're using machine learning algorithms
and neural networks to process these
and identify them at scale.
If we were to do this in the ocean at the
scale of the problem, we need to have,
we need to match the scale of observation
and the scale of analysis to the scale
of the problem.
And that's an ocean.
So we're using autonomous observation
drones and we're using autonomous analysis
and machine learning. But what I
really want to talk about is this.
Um, you all are familiar with
search searches, everything,
but you can't do search
if you don't have memory.
And so if you don't have memory, you have
nothing. What we're trying to do, uh,
we just opened a new lab in our
conservation, a research group,
and it's called the ocean memory lab.
And the idea behind this lab is that we
are trying to build longterm records,
a ecological records of the ocean so we
can have proper baselines for ecosystem
health if we don't have that
memory of what a healthy ocean is,
not just the last 10 years, not the
last 40 years, way beyond my lifetime,
hundreds of years.
How do we build that record?
Because that record is absolutely
integral for understanding where we are,
where we need to get back to, and then
perhaps in paths on how to get there.
So this is an important,
an incredibly important plot is this
carbon dioxide concentration in the
atmosphere as measured from the Mount
of Loa observatory on the Big Island of
Hawaii. And so this is just what I want
to show you is this magic red line.
Let's think of that as a baseline.
400 parts per million of carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere is aligned that we had
kind of set several years ago is
something we never wanted to cross.
What we've crossed it.
We crossed it and a 2015,
I think for the first time and you
can see there's a seasonal cycle,
sort of the air, the planet
breathing rather. And um,
it goes up and down with the northern
hemisphere forest in the winter being
deciduous and losing their
leaves and the ocean cycle.
Now as I go back and as
I add more data to that,
you can see how far apart the historical
observation is from that red line that
we didn't want to cross in 400.
We go back to 1950.
You go back to 1900,
we'd go back to 1800 and we
can even go back further now.
How do you think that
this graph was built?
You can see there's sort of three
different sections of the graph. Well,
the first part, we can
go back even further. Um,
the first part is done with an instrument
measuring it beginning in 1958.
You know,
when you've made a good scientific figure,
when they in bronze it and put it
on the side of a building, right?
It should be like every scientist
goal that they'll end bronze.
I figure that I've made and maybe my
restaurant menus when we'll get there
someday, but, but, um,
but, but not today. So, um,
keeling from Scripps Institute of
Oceanography started these measurements in
1958 and then when they said, you
know, you're onto something here,
but we need more data.
We wish you had done that in 1758.
But of course we didn't have sensors,
so how do you think they
went back and build it?
They went through glacial ice cores and
went to Antarctica and dozens of teams
from all over the world of international
collaborators have worked to build this
together. But this plot is
called the keeling curve, right?
And this is the absolute
important baseline for us to
measure climate change and
where we are today.
This is what began at all really.
And we don't have one
of these for plastic.
We don't have one of these for a lot of
problems. So how do we build this memory?
Well,
let's go back to this idea of drones.
There is a drone inside.
There's a payload with uh,
data and observation scheme,
some sore sensors, uh,
some sort of propulsion, there is
energy, there's battery of some sort.
And then probably some sort of way to
transmit the data back to moss landing to
Ambari. Well, what I
would go out to embargo,
I say I've been working with
drones my entire professional life,
but I've never touched one
of those things. I have
touched one of these things.
This is a sea turtle
shell. And what my, uh,
my ideas that actually animals are drones.
They are,
they have long,
they have tissues that they take data
on their ecosystem experience and are
recording it and our learning all sorts
of stuff about the conditions of the
ocean.
So let me explain that a bit more.
That's a hawksbill sea turtle
right there. Uh, this turtle, uh,
uh, died many years ago and it was in
a freezer in Hawaii when I got there.
And then we did a necropsy on it. It had
been in a freezer since 1992 and I said,
well,
let's learn something about this animal
that met a bad end and maybe we can get
some information about how to manage
the population better. So this animal,
obviously a beautiful show was
not hunted historically for it's,
it's a neat,
it was used for its show and you
can see why it's gorgeous and,
but the thing is within
that and within that Shell,
my idea was that there's probably a
lot of data. So to first we need a,
we need some sort of
baseline record of time.
And so this is one way
we go about doing this.
This is obviously a nuclear test in,
uh,
probably several kilometers away from
where that animal actually died that I
just showed you. And this is in the
Marshall Islands. Um, you can see, um,
that this is injecting all sorts of
heavy carbon into the atmosphere,
radiocarbon or 14 carbon.
And what we can do is we can get a map
of the memory of that radioactive carbon
in the system through corals.
And we did this in Hawaii.
And you can just see the levels of
radiocarbon are pretty much low background
baseline until about 1950 and
then they start to uptick.
They peak in the late sixties
early seventies depending
on where you are on the
planet and then they start to decline
with a nuclear test ban treaty, right?
But this right here is a,
is a very helpful,
a calendar of radiocarbon that we can
use to understand the timing of these
different animals in the ocean. Some of
the most basic things about wildlife,
like a Bluefin tuna or a blue whale
or even a sea turtle is how old is it?
How long is it going to live? Where
did it come from, where was it born,
where is it going to breed?
These basic questions are really elusive.
This is a cross section of one of
those shells that I showed you earlier.
We know this animal died in 1976 but
we can micro sample along the various
gradients, kind of like the
grains on a log of wood, right?
But one line isn't necessarily one year.
And so what we do is we use tools much
like what your dentist will use to fix a
cavity, a very small, precise drill.
And we drill out powder from
there and we analyze the isotopes.
And using the radio,
carbon isotopes or bomb radiocarbon,
we can actually go back and date each
one of those sections and say, oh,
this animal was born in 1953 at dot.
In 1976 it was 23 years old.
Um, now we can say, oh, this
isn't just a sea turtle shell.
It's a clock,
but it's also a passport.
It's also a recording toxins and
it's also recording temperature.
There are literally dozens of things we
can get out of that Shell to understand
the experience of that individual
turtle that we can build a record of its
environment. So let me give you a
another example. But before I do that,
I want to explain to you marine food webs
in a very sort of cartoony basic kind
of way. Um, at the very
basic level we have the sun,
which is it's trophic position
or trophic level is zero.
Something that eats only
the sun is trophic position
of one like phytoplankton.
Something that only eats phytoplankton
is going to be to something that only
eats that like a small, like a sardine
or something is going to be three.
A tuna that eats that is going to be
four and then something that eats that is
going to be five so there
are these changes that you
when you go up the food web.
Now,
one of the things that people have looked
over time is to measure the aggregate
performance of a fishery.
By getting its mean trophic levels,
so you look at all the
fish that were caught,
you assign a trophic level to each one,
you weight it by the mass,
and then you just scale up.
Now if you look at over time in
different parts of the ocean,
this is the northwest Atlantic, the
northeast Atlantic, the southeast Pacific,
and then the Mediterranean.
You can see as catchin fish goes up,
the trophic position goes down.
That means those food webs are,
those chains are getting smaller.
That's something we want to avoid because
that means the systems are getting
simpler, less complex, less resilient,
and they're losing some
of the top predators.
Now this has been a subject of a lot of
debates gone back and forth because when
you use fisheries data to measure
the performance of a fishery,
there are inherent biases.
Um,
what you can see in this plot and the
lower left is the importance of anchovy.
When the anchovy catch goes up,
the trophic position of the aggregate
fishery goes way down because it's a low
foraging fish, right? And so there's
been a lot of debate about this. Well,
one of the things we said is trophic
level, kind of an interesting idea,
but maybe if we don't use fisheries
data to measure it, maybe if we use,
because it has inherent economic biases.
What if people decide they don't
want to use anchovies anymore?
They want to use natural fertilizer
instead of fish fertilizer.
What if there is a moratorium and the u
s on a certain kind of fishery that'll
change the catch.
So the ecosystem isn't changing.
It's just the economic rules are changing,
right?
So we actually want to measure what
we're interested in measuring without
artifacts. It's a huge
issue in an observation and
measurement, right? So we said,
why don't we look at these birds because
they're also interested in eating fish
and they're like us. They're searching
the ocean for top predatorial fish. Um,
but they're not subject to
economic constraints like we are.
And one of the things about those cool
drones that embargo it and other people
make is they're fascinating,
but they can't go back in time.
They're not time machines.
But working with museums and repositories,
we can actually go back in time.
And that study I just showed you
those kind of weighing things,
they're based on fisheries statistics,
which are largely after World War Two.
So you're limited to dated
back to 1950 of course,
the ocean was changing before 1950 of
course we were fishing before 1950 of
course,
climate change was happening before
1950 so let's go back before 1950 but in
order to do that,
we have to be creative.
And so we started going to
museums and getting seabirds.
These birds are from the late 18 hundreds
and we can measure throughout time
there trophic position by looking at the
ratio of amino acids in their feathers.
So these birds have thousands of feathers.
These are precious specimens.
We don't want to harm the, but we
can just go in and take two feathers.
You'd net the bird never knows
we, we came in left, right?
And even an expert would not even
know that we took those feathers.
We take body feathers,
we don't take the beautiful long primary
flight feathers that like the kinds
you're used to like dipping in an
ink bottle and write writing with.
Now these are like the downy feathers
in the breast. We take two of these,
there's another 900, there's another
9,000 they're waiting left. And um,
but importantly, these
resources are already there.
National history repositories,
museum's collections.
There are,
these are all over the world and they're
literally just data archives sitting in
a drawer,
right?
And so we're trying to tap some of the
potential of these to understand longterm
trends in the ocean.
We went and use this technique called
compound specific stable isotope analysis
in amino acids kind of
rolls off the tongue,
but what we can do is similar
to the heavy carbon theory,
this does not a radioisotope this,
this is a stable isotope,
but we can look at where they are in the
food level based on the nitrogen that
they're accruing to heavy nitrogen.
And what we found in looking at eight
different species is that you can see in
the lower left that pink
plot is an ensemble of all
those pieces of birds there.
Trophic position is declining and it's
almost exactly the same magnitude of
decline as was measured
in the fisheries data.
But what's really cool about this is
because they're birds and people are
fascinated by birds,
and I'm studied for birds for a long time,
is we actually know the Diet
of these birds because those,
that dot on there with a huge error bars
is one point in time where some of my
colleagues in Hawaii actually captured
a lot of these birds and looked at their
stomach contents and basically got the
stomach contents of hundreds of seabirds,
which you can imagine what that
experience was like. Um, it was,
it was a little pungent, I
would say. Um, but nonetheless,
they reconstructed the diets of all
these animals and we can then we have two
sources of data. Now we have diet
contents, which are pretty primary source,
and then we reconstructed it from the
amino acids in their feathers beginning in
1890 and then sequentially
over time to today.
Now what we can do is we have the
trophic levels and we have a diets we can
actually solve for x and we can
actually look at their diets. Over time.
We can reconstruct what the diets would
have been to produce those trophic
levels. And what we can see
if you look in the lower left,
the ensemble for the all species is that
squid populations in the North Pacific
have doubled in the last
hundred and 30 years.
So that's just describing what's happening
right through the feathers. This is a,
an albatross a and Albatross of course.
It's an uh,
very well known for its ability to fly
very efficiently over long areas in
search La, huge areas of the ocean
with very little energy expended.
You may not know this,
but its wing is the archetype for the
Mars plane that's being designed right now
by NASA. This plane has no,
propulsion is just a glider.
They're going to drop it in the outer
atmosphere of Mars and it's just going to
descend hopefully at a very slow rate.
They're hoping for three minutes because
the atmosphere has never been measured
in Mars. They have a rover
but they don't have a plane.
But the design of his wing has called
a Prendall weeing and it's designed
basically off the same
principles as an albatross wing.
So it's a pretty good flyer that's on
how to say. Um, but now that we have,
we can say the trophic positions
have changed over time.
The fish that they're eating has changed
over time. Why is that happening?
Well,
here it comes to machine learning again,
we can take various
measurements of eco morphology.
We take various measurements of the
climate data in the North Pacific and we
take various ways a data streams,
a fisheries,
and we can say all these things could
be affecting why these birds and they're
trophic position is declining.
It could be the birds themselves.
Some of them are really
great flyers like Albatross.
Some of them are a little chunkier and
have shorter wings and can't fly as far.
Um, then we have all these
things going on with climate.
We have all these things going on
with fisheries. So what's causing it.
And so we can run and
apply machine learning,
random forest algorithms and
build models to understand this,
that the human eye or some more standard
statistical methods like general
linearized models can't do.
And we can say that from all of this.
I will tell you that all of those things
matter because these animals don't get
driven by one variable.
They get driven by many variables because
the ocean is a multidisciplinary space.
So if you're an albatross,
you can fly further.
But climate change is also happening.
And commercial fisheries are also taking
your preferred fish out of the ocean.
And so we can do all of those things.
But the important point that I'm trying
to say here is that we started with
feathers.
We started with birds in a drawer
that weren't being used for anything.
And we were able to build this whole
story about how the ocean is changing and
how squid populations are growing just
from looking at amino acids in bird
feathers.
So let me give you another example.
Back to home again,
the Monterey Bay.
I mentioned that we have our roots
in the, uh, Stanford, uh, marine lab,
which is right next door.
Hopkins Marine Lab.
They've been there at that
location for a hundred years.
And they have been every morning since
the early 19 hundreds have been the
docent in charge,
uh,
go out and ADM dip a bucket
of water into the ocean,
put a thermometer in it and
measure the temperature.
Now they did that every day of the
week except Sunday for about 10 years.
And then they were like, well, to hell
with that was with the Sunday too. And uh,
so we have this really cool data record,
but we had,
this is going back to instruments
versus proxies, right? About 1919.
We have those data records
on the temperature of the
ocean every morning at ADM.
So from those data,
we can learn a few things.
We can look at the average temperature,
but often what's really
important is the extremes.
So if I just look at that time
series of thermometer in a bucket,
ADM from our colleagues next door,
we can see that the hottest week of
the year has changed and has become two
degrees c hotter today than it was
when they first started in 1919.
Okay. So think about that. May
Say, well to seat isn't terrible,
maybe it's not great. Um, but then if
you look at another way of measuring it,
if we look at when that hot week is not
just how hot is that week, the extreme,
the, you know, the 50 the
first hottest week of the year,
but not just how hot does it,
but when does it occur and it
occurs about 10 days earlier.
So that's not only happening,
it's a higher magnitude of heat,
but it's actually occurring
earlier in the year.
Not a huge surprise I those things.
But then if you actually say,
let's not look at weeks, let's look at
days and let's look at extreme heat days.
This is where it really gets interesting.
And we see there are now 68 more extreme
heat days than there were a hundred
years ago.
This is just one century in one place.
And this is the value of data
we wouldn't be able to have.
We'll be able to search these records
and come up with these statistics are how
these metrics,
if we didn't have the memory right,
but we can actually go back further
than when they were measuring with a
thermometer with um, with a human
actually going out there with the sensor.
And that's actually with macro algae.
People have been collecting algae
probably as long as people have been going
into the ocean. It's really easy
to do. Um, it basically, uh,
the procedure goes like this.
You reach down,
you pick up the algae and you
put in your pocket. You know,
it's a little bit more complex. Usually
you press it between two pieces of paper.
But we have an herbarium at the aquarium
called the herbarium aquarium or
Barium.
And we've been collecting since the late
seventies when we started scoping out
what we were going to win. The aquarium
started getting designed and build.
But our neighbors next door have been
collecting algae since the 1890s and even
before a little bit. So
this is the same, uh,
jenness of red algae callow Phyllis.
And you can see that even though it's
been kept between two pieces of paper for
100 and uh, almost 30
years, it looks spread.
It still looks the same and it's
in remarkably good condition.
So what we can do is we can actually
recreate the temperature of the ocean in
which that Alga specimen lived.
By looking at the oxygen isotopes,
we can look at the
nutrients in that ocean.
We can look at the pollution in that
ocean. We can look at, this is a,
this is an organism that roots in
the bottom. So it didn't migrate.
So we can't say, oh, what's it's passport?
Did it go to Japan and come back?
It did not do that. We can say
that right now with no one sees.
But this is really important. And so what
we're now doing is trying to say, well,
these are all our specimens over time.
We didn't collect it equal amounts,
but we can go back and use these
algae or we can use birds are,
we can use tuna,
we can use auditors,
we can use sharks to really
learn a ton about the ocean.
And we just need to sort of go
into the memory, find the platform,
find the drone,
whatever animal or plant that is,
get the sensor out of it and then
recreate that. Thank you very much.
[inaudible] if
you could prioritize,
I'm sort of interventions,
do you have anything you would call out?
What sort of interventions
or to like to improve?
Like if we're going on this downward
trend, um, in a lot of ways,
do you have suggestions of focus areas,
you know,
for all of us as consumers are,
you know, I think one of the, uh,
before we get there, I think the, um,
it's an important question and it's,
it's the obvious question I think.
Uh,
how do you prioritize what problems
to address and then cause you can't do
everything, but let's just say it's
difficult to do everything. Um,
I would say that one of the issues that's
been really fascinating as a scientist
and a conservationist to observe is
the public engagement on the issue of
microplastic. We were not really concerned
and talking about that 10 years ago,
that is not a new issue.
It's been identified for a while.
It just really seems to have captured
the environmental consciousness and even
the public consciousness is what do we,
the garbage patch.
And I think the way that we think
about that is now that we know,
let's do something about it.
Right?
That's why Sylvia Earle and others
would say something like that.
I think that's a, that's a really good
way. Now that we have the information,
now that we have the data, what are we
gonna what are we gonna do about it?
I think when it comes to plastic,
the easiest thing to do is to
not use single use plastic,
a throwaway or recyclable water bottle
that basically has a one use lifetime and
then it gets repurposed to something else.
Um,
and so what I would say is that's
the easiest thing to address,
but it's pervasive. You see single use
plastic and a lot of different places.
Um, and I think that would be
something that you can immediately do.
I think the choices that we make
when it comes to climate change,
which probably, um, the, the,
one of the things that I've heard in these
are very difficult things to measure.
But if we were to stop looking at the
issue of climate change versus issue a
plastic, what's more important?
Um, if we were to stop,
if we had a magic button that we
could turn off all carbon emissions,
we could go carbon neutral today.
We would still be dealing with the problem
of climate change 1000 years from now
because the earth's climate system
is so complex and the ocean is a huge
reservoir of heat that it takes a
long time for things to equilibrate.
One of the reasons that perhaps climate
change isn't as severe today as it we
might think it would be is because the
ocean is holding so much of the heat.
And so it's like this buffer that's
controlling, um, our climate system.
So a thousand years for climate.
If we were to do the same kind of thing
and magically turn off our plastic and
microplastic pollution switch,
we would probably be dealing
with this for another 40 years.
Very different magnitude of the problem.
So climate is probably something that
is going to affect everyone and has been
for decades.
And I would say the choice,
the choices that we make in terms of
our carbon emissions and our carbon
consumption are massive. The food
that you eat, the travel that you do,
the people tuning in from other
places that didn't fly here,
that actually are just tuning
in online. Great Choice. Um,
and I think we just need to
prioritize those decisions.
We're even looking at this
in our research programs.
We have three different research projects
that we could do and we're evaluating
right now. Well, how does
sustainability factor into this?
These are all three very, this
is the, it's a, we have a great,
we have a great problem. We have three
fascinating research programs. What, um,
one project on acts one project
on why one project on Z,
but they're not all the same in
terms of their carbon consumption.
Some of them would be maybe require
more energy and that's into our
consciousness right now
about how we prioritize and
choose projects for just for
research.
Is there any policy compliant you would
add to the plastic space, you know,
in terms of an intervention you wish.
So I'm a scientist and we have a lot
of policy experts that we work with,
but I would say that uh,
policies addressing single use plastic
plastic is so pervasive in our society.
I'm probably am holding plastic
in my hand right now. Um,
but I'm not going to
recycle it or throw it away.
I'm going to use it for a very long
time. And I would say that, uh,
policies relating to single use
plastic are just things that we need to
incentivize that going away. First
of all, thank you so much for coming.
That took was amazing. I
think we all agree. Uh,
one question I was wondering about is,
um,
so you talked about this memory lab
that your guys aren't building is,
but you also talked about the creative
ways that you use together all the data
that is, you know, hidden everywhere
and very difficult to find.
So it was just wondering is the goal
to open up their lab to everyone?
And I don't know if I have feathers
in my room from 10 years ago. Like,
are you going to encourage
people to participate and, um,
put the data that they might have at
the disposal of the aquarium and also,
uh, are you going to make
the data available to other
scientists and Greg, uh,
other people? That's a great
question. So the first thing is,
I want to say is I've had written
above my desk for a long time.
More data is more better, right?
Even though the grammar isn't great,
the people get what I
mean by that. Um, so, uh,
when I was doing the menu's project in
Hawaii, we, there's this thing in Hawaii,
you may not have heard of
it called coconut wireless.
It's the word getting out.
You know, um, it's a, it's a, it's a
joke of course is the gossip train.
And, uh, when I was
working on this project,
coconut wireless who is in full
effect and I would get people, um,
and then when we published
the study and it was on NPR,
I got a lot of random solicitations.
People just sent me stuff in the mail.
But I would get calls and saying,
Hey, I have five menus from 1960.
Do you want them? And I'm like,
yes, of course I do. So, um,
when it comes to wildlife,
it's a little trick here because do you
tend to any permits? So we wouldn't say,
hey, here's a, here's an open data call
for sea bird feathers because we want the,
the pros to do that, um, and permitted
fashion. But I would say that, um,
yes, there will be, we are going to
be increasingly communicating, uh,
with the general public about ways they
can get involved and contribute data to
our, to our projects. And as we do that,
I think that's an incredible point cause
crowdsourcing and involving citizens
science is a, is a very big
component of where we're going.
On the second question about open,
open access, open source. Um,
we're a nonprofit and it's,
it's one of our core values to be open
access and open source Ambari. Um,
they make some amazing devices and
then they put the blueprints online.
It's really amazing that they, that
um, because they're the same, they're,
they had the same DNA as we do.
Uh, we want to be open access.
So we use open science framework,
we use get hub,
we use fixed share research gate.
We put all of our publications online.
We're increasingly trying to work with
only open access journals because we want
to work with people all over the world
who may not have access to a university
library in which those things are
free and openly available. So we,
it's a huge value of ours
to make our data accessible,
to invite people into our
research projects in a way
that they can meaningfully
contribute. I mean, be a
coauthor in our work. Um,
we want to solve problems and we know
we need more data and more experts.
We firmly believe in the theory of plenty
at the more eyes and the more minds
you have in a project,
the more comes out of it.
It's not like we have to Gollum it.
Um, so we can get all the glory.
That's not our position at all. We want
to, um, open science, open access is,
is where we are. So yes, and we're,
we're building the data infrastructure
to make that seamlessly happen.
And then the user interface,
it's very intuitive.
I think some of the problems that were
actually, I'll go even a step further.
Some of the problems
that we're dealing with,
everyone in this room may be in the
choir and maybe like super onboard,
but there,
let's be honest,
there are some more difficult issues
that aren't so obvious and have to get
people with disparate beliefs and
political persuasions to agree on.
So one of the things that we're doing
when we publish a paper or now a
publishing, uh, transparent gooeys uh,
graphical user interfaces to let people
say, well we did the study this way,
but if you pull the dials in different
ways you can get a different answer.
So some of the problems we're solving,
we're trying to actually recruit,
do it a different way and I think that's
where science is going to be going with
much more interactive where the,
the analytical framework is on the
backend and you just have a user interface
and you're using machine learning,
you're just pushing little dials with
your mouse and that's where we're going to
be going through things like um,
um,
the frameworks usually on the ar
platform where we can do this.
Yeah. What you were just
referring to with how you're
building your research now so that it
can be more presentable to people with
other views.
Is that how you're making
it more open to things like,
um,
getting fisheries onboard for things like
cds with Bluefin and things like that?
Cause I know in the past it's been a
challenge to get the fisheries and other
people, lobbyists, stuff like that on
board with getting protected fisheries,
all of that, all of that
fun stuff integrated. Um,
just the challenge of having
an species protected and sure,
scientists working together with all of
that, you can put it more eloquently.
I'll let you do that.
So that's the main question.
Is there a way to get science working
together with people who wish to deny
science or use it in a way,
um, that supports fisheries
versus science? Sure.
It's a great question. I
would say that, um, oh,
what I would say is that a lot of people
care about Bluefin tuna for different
reasons. And um, I think everyone
pretty much cares about bluefin tuna,
h just for different incentives and their
incentives are prioritized differently.
If you're a Bluefin tuna fishermen,
you can't fish for blue's name if
there are no bluefin. So, um, it's,
it's in everyone's interest
for there to be Bluefin tuna.
It's just how much are
extracted every year.
But I think that what you're getting at
is exactly the point is that when we do
analyses and we come to conclusion,
we not only want to be transparent
about the data, about how he got there,
but then we say,
and here,
here's the interactive where you
can choose your own incentives.
Think about a situation like, um, um,
choosing where to put a marine protected
area and preserve in the ocean.
Um,
if your incentives are to protect climate
change or to rebuild fisheries or to
have a variety of other things,
those places could show up differently
in the ocean to protect biodiversity. Um,
and what we can do is we can
say, here are the 10 most, uh,
that the top 10 market share of
ideas for ocean conservation,
for marine protected areas.
We can build those data layers there,
exists now and we could say,
and you can weight them however you
want this one 10, this one, zero,
this one five.
And then it gives you a map.
That's what we're working on right now.
It was kinds of interactive
with the success at places like problem
Fomo is easier to prove that it's
capable to bring back the species and
biodiversity easier to show the fisheries
and official manner that it
is possible to bring it back.
It's been wiped out such
a manner.
So there you mentioned Cabo Pomo,
there's some great success
stories of conservation working.
I would just look at the great whales
in the Pacific Ocean blue whale,
humpback whale gray whale.
These are basically candidates
for removing from the
endangered species list now,
um, because their populations have
been growing at three to 6% a year, um,
ever since they put a moratorium
on whaling. And so, uh,
what's amazing is if you don't
kill whales, they actually do well.
And I think that's something
everyone agrees on one. Um,
and so there was a lot
of examples like that.
And so it's just how do you get
protection? How do you get to,
how do you serve the dual mandate of
commercial fisheries and conservation?
That's the question.
And how much do you weigh in which one?
And I think when you move
towards it, a data rich, open,
relatable, interactive
framework, a lot of the,
a lot of the disagreements can
be a back beat, can be about,
we don't trust your data,
we don't trust your methods and,
and you're doing it behind closed doors
and not inviting us to be a part of it.
Well, all of those disagreements go
away when you make the data available.
When you make the processes transparent
and rational and when you make their
interactives online,
that really anyone can,
can very intuitively understand.
And that's what I think is we're
trying to meet everyone where that,
cause all of those complaints are
totally valid. We don't want secret data.
We don't want to secret methods.
We don't have any secret rooms with secret
decisions when it all to be out there.
The whole point of science is that it's,
it's a Galitary and a
democratic and accessible. Um,
and so we need to have the infrastructures
and the platforms to make it that way.
So when you were talking about the keeling
curve measuring the co two levels and
uh, that at 1958 and onwards I think, uh,
we have an instrument
that I guess is very,
very good at this and
before it's more of a proxy,
how do you align the data from the two
and possibly even maybe many disparate
historical sources.
How do you make sure that they are
calibrated or that sort of thing for
something like this with
the ocean when we left, hmm.
I think it's like a symphony.
You have a bunch of different instruments
and you're trying to make a coherent
narrative out of it. And
uh, when it comes to,
I'm less of an expert on the COO
two series and it, that is a,
is a lot of research groups from a lot
of countries and a lot of NSF funding and
a lot of major programs that went
into building that curve. It May,
you may look at that curve and say,
oh,
it's just a simple graph and it's
so much work went into that graph.
Sometimes when you look at the
figures and we can just scrape data,
put a cool vis together in like an hour,
and then you look at something like that.
And that is like PhDs and careers in a
wards in the huge amount of effort went
into that.
But getting,
getting together a proxy and a calibrated
Dataset is usually the beginning of a
lot of the thought of some of our
projects is we start with some sort of
training set and then we
start with something that
we think is a good proxy and
how do we add those two together so that
we can take the training set away and
then we can do it at scale. This is
what we're doing with microplastic.
When we look at the
Ramond laser spectroscopy,
we trained the spectra on known types
and then we go out and we do the proxies.
The problem is is that plastic in the
ocean is been tumbled around in the waves
are at depth,
extreme temperatures,
different acidities in an
animal's stomach for a while.
So it's a lot not pristine.
So we,
but that's actually part of the magic
because we can actually now using
spectroscopy, we're working to
age some of these particles.
We can say not only is it nylon,
but it's nylon has been
in the ocean for 40 years.
That's really helpful
information as opposed to saying,
well 40% of it's not on 40%
of its polycarbon and in
40% of its polyamide or has
more than a hundred percent but
um, but you, you get the idea.
But I think just having those training
sets, when you go back in time,
the error bars can get a little broader.
And so it's just,
the question is just realizing the limits
of your data and using a training set
that is unassailable. I say that's
our general approach going about it.
Some proxies are, are more difficult than
others and sometimes it's a proxy of,
it's like a metro,
she Goodall of data and then you get
that little thing on the inside. Right.
And we want to have,
we wanted to kind of limit our proxies,
but it's amazing what you can do if
you have some data to begin with.
As opposed to nothing.
Thank you very much.